mi historia comienza en el año 2016 era
un día miércoles recuerdo que estaba en
el trabajo al mediodía y recibió el
llamado de julio un amigo de los eeuu
con julio nos habíamos conocido algunos
meses en una feria internacional de
tecnología donde le recorrimos juntos de
punta a punta atiende el teléfono y me
dice matías cómo estás la verdad que
sorprendido por su llamado iniciamos
para preguntarte si tenés la visa al día
y si tenés 7 días libres para hacer un
viaje imagínenme respuesta obvio
y me dice ok te llamo un rato vengo
cruzando el golden gate tengo muy poca
señal
un abrazo
recuerdo que ese día vuelo a mi casa del
trabajo y ansioso como soy les juro que
caminaban por las paredes
en eso me llama nuevamente y me dice
matías te invito a un programa de
inmersión en silicon valley que comienza
este mismo domingo
desde ese miércoles hasta el domingo
sólo pude pensar en esto
para los que lo conocen esta es la cd
de apple en california en la bahía de
san francisco y es un lugar emblemático
y se preguntarán por qué me olía tan
loco hacer este programa y hacer este
viaje lo cierto es que desde chico
siempre amé la tecnología
tal es así que recuerdo que tenía 12
años mi tío me regale una computadora y
creo que tarde siete días en desarmarla
y la curiosidad que me genera
pero no sólo eso también había otras
razones
danielle la persona con la que trabajo
desde hace 12 años había hecho ese mismo
programa el año anterior y había vuelto
daniel x 10 estaba enloquecido quería
cambiar el mundo tenía un montón de
ideas creo que comenzó hacemos una nueva
empresa
pero a su vez también me llama muchísimo
la atención conocer empresas como google
como facebook que son empresas que
trascienden fronteras y que generan
productos globales y ahí estaba yo el
primer día del programa obviamente feliz
de poder visitar ese lugar que qué
ansiada desde esa semana
pero lo cierto es que él es uno de los
momentos más importantes viene después
donde tenemos otra reunión con todo el
resto del equipo éramos prácticamente
todos latinos en busca de vivir la misma
experiencia y nos entregan este libro
los secretos de silicon valley y ahí
cambió mi modo de ver las cosas
para la próxima charla
me centre en las personas me centre en
conocer sus experiencias sus vivencias
conocer qué piensan que sienten que
estudian cómo hacen para diseñar y
producir esos productos y servicios que
consumimos en todo el mundo
y así fue por ejemplo que me concentre
en la historia que nos contaba este
gigante jonathan nelson
una persona que nació en honduras que se
fue a vivir eeuu enfermero
y que le costó muchísimo emprender en
eeuu entonces en un bar con unas amigas
decidió crear hacker en founders para
hacer más fácil el acceso al capital de
riesgo a los emprendedores que vienen de
otros países así eeuu y hoy lleva
millones de dólares invertidos en
talento de otros países
con esa y con otras historias más
completamos el viaje pero llegará el
momento de conocer la ciudad de san
francisco
la ciudad del puente la ciudad que
veíamos al comienzo
y a medida que íbamos llegando en el
auto nos topamos con esto la hora que
nunca había visto una congestión tan
importante como esta
obviamente que preocupados por llegar a
tiempo a la próxima reunión miguel el
coordinador del programa nos dice no se
preocupen
ahí estamos con miel en su auto
eléctrico hacía muy poquitas semanas que
se lo habían entregado y nos dice
relájense vamos a tomar el carril de la
izquierda
en función de que california tiene una
serie de leyes que permiten que aquellos
que opten por movilidad eléctrica o que
hagan car pooling puedan tomar este tipo
de accesos más rápidos en la ciudad
y así fue que finalmente pudimos llegar
a la próxima reunión y reunirnos con
todo el equipo
con todas estas experiencias arme la
valija y llegó el momento de volver
o sea en córdoba argentina
realizamos un evento
en ese evento tuvimos la posibilidad de
conocer un grupo de ingenieros
cordobeses que tenían la idea de
desarrollo en un vehículo eléctrico
y la verdad es que comenzamos a charlar
y
y nos preguntamos si tendrá sentido
valdrá la pena no es muy difícil la
respuesta es siempre la misma porque no
y así comenzó el desafío y así nació gol
motors estábamos decididos a producir un
vehículo 100% eléctrico desde argentina
y para hacerlo empezamos a pensar en las
cosas que había vivido en este viaje y
rescataba 3
primero pensar global pensar diferente
y dejar una huella
pensar global qué frase más trillado
seguramente le habrán escuchado cientos
o miles de veces
pero me acuerdo que caminando las calles
de san francisco ya todos los
emprendedores y todas las personas
tienen ese pensamiento cada vez que
consiguen una idea piensan que el mundo
es el mercado
entonces lo primero que hicimos fue
investigar qué hacía el mundo en materia
de vehículos eléctricos que se hacían en
eeuu que se hacían europa y así basamos
todos los estándares de normas y de
seguridad de nuestros vehículos en
función a esta premisa a su vez esta
decisión hoy nos permite pensar en el
día de mañana en mercados globales
porque no
pensar diferente recuerdo que cuando
charlamos con miel no sólo le importaba
el hecho de tener un vehículo por la
novedad sino que también le importaban
otras cosas como él nos decía mira puedo
dejar mi auto estacionado cerca de mi
casa y no pagar parking
pero también puedo dejarlo cargando
gratis de por vida encima
y ahí entendía que a este tipo de
personas también les importa el ahorro
entonces nos pusimos a pensar ya
trabajar en eso y tratamos de darle una
vuelta de rosca a la carrocería del
vehículo y fue así que como nuestros
ingenieros venían de la industria
aerospacial tratamos de diseñar
vehículos con materiales compuestos los
cuales permiten generar vehículos muy
livianos
qué
permiten hacer 100 kilómetros por el
costo de una tacita de café
dejar una huella
si hoy están emprendiendo
deben pensar en el impacto que genera
ese emprendimiento que por lo general
los alientos que perciben el objetivo
una empresa de triple impacto o una
empresa que tiene tres objetivos impacto
social el impacto económico e impacto
ambiental
recuerdo las charlas con jonathan es
gigante y como él había impactado
socialmente y un día me recuerdo que
estamos en la empresa haciendo una nota
sacamos una foto y esa foto me llamó
mucho la atención había sólo dos mujeres
la verdad que ahí había algo que no
estaba bien que no estamos haciendo bien
así que nos juntamos con todo el equipo
y de ese momento en adelante todas las
búsquedas de talento que hacíamos en
nuestras redes
incluían la figura de mujeres
técnicas operarias diseñadoras
ingenieras etcétera etcétera
entonces uno sin darse cuenta cuando
toma este tipo de decisiones se está
generando impacto social permanentemente
los invito a reflexionar que pueden
ustedes hacer para cambiar esa
desigualdad social
impacto económico me acuerdo que en esas
charlas también nos presentaban un
montón de datos
y estadísticas y podría rescatar algo
muy valioso en silicon valley solo tres
millones de personas llegaban a generar
un pp y per cápita anual de 160 mil
dólares y en argentina logramos 12 mil
500 dólares menos del 10 por ciento la
verdad que es en realidad me impactó
y ahí puede entender de qué se trataba
la economía el conocimiento si recuerdan
yo fui pensando en los edificios después
me encontré con las historias de las
personas y cuando recordamos cuando
recorrimos la ciudad no habíamos campos
no veíamos fábricas de esto se trataba
la economía del conocimiento
de personas buscando cambiar el mundo y
generando productos globales
entonces hoy con la empresa tratamos de
generar productos con mucho valor
agregado nacional y también alentamos a
que emprendedores locales puedan sumarse
a este sueño de la movilidad eléctrica y
tal es así que aquí pueden ver dos
vehículos dos cargadores para vehículos
eléctricos íntegramente desarrollados en
la provincia de córdoba
impacto ambiental en su paso por córdoba
un político internacional premio nobel
de la paz dijo una frase que se me grado
para siempre somos la primera generación
en advertir los efectos del cambio
climático y la última que pueda hacer
algo al respecto esto nos recuerda que
no tenemos tiempo debemos actuar ya
tuve la suerte de participar en un
evento y conocer a agustín austin
trabaja para la onu medio ambiente
y con él venimos trabajando desde hace
tiempo en la agenda de las ciudades de
latinoamérica para lograr ese ambicioso
objetivo de hacer misiones hacia 2050 y
para ellos trabajamos con empresarios
con intendentes y con gobiernos de un
montón de ciudades buscando generar un
impacto positivo y buscando cambiar las
ciudades del futuro entonces si ustedes
se encontrase en frente a esta situación
en la que tuviesen que elegir un camino
cualquiera en que elegirían
los invito a avanzar juntos por el
camino que conduce un mundo mejor
gracias